Among the many shocking developments in Avengers:
Endgame, Thor's transformation from buff God
of Thunder to depressed dad bod has to rank
near the top of the list and while there's
a lot to love about this narrative twist,
it's far from perfect.
Here are the three best and worst things about
Thick Thor.
Heroes always have their low points, but Thor's
is pretty darn low.
He spends the bulk of Infinity War off on
his own side quest in the hopes of coming
back with a weapon that could ultimately turn
the tide and it almost does, too.
When we get to Endgame, though, Thor isn't
just distracted by his own motivations and
plans, he's completely lost his way.
Throughout much of Endgame, "Bro Thor," as
Marvel officially labels him in a Blu-ray
featurette, continually makes poor decisions
and prioritizes his own needs over everyone
else's.
This is immediately made clear when Rocket
and Professor Hulk arrive in New Asgard to
find that the "king" is hiding away playing
video games and only interacts with his people
in order to restock on beer.
And what about when he time travels to Asgard
with Rocket in order to extract the Aether
from his old flame, Jane Foster?
He crumbles in fear as soon as the rubber
hits the road, needing Rocket's tough-guy
pep talk to help him turn a corner.
Which even then, doesn’t work!
"I think I'm having a panic attack."
"Get it together!"
By the time Avengers and Thor: The Dark World
rolled around, the one-dimensional aspect
of Thor's character as a musclebound hero
was getting old fast.
The early manifestations of the son of Odin
were powerful and all, but there just wasn't
much substance there … that is, until director
Taika Waititi arrived on the scene.
Thor: Ragnarok reinvigorated the Thor franchise
with a humorous energy that thrilled audiences
across the board.
The threequel strips down Thor's story to
its emotionally raw underpinnings and provides
the perfect springboard to carry the character
through his vengeful mission in Avengers:
Infinity War.
In Endgame, the "Bro Thor" narrative twists
the story even further, dragging the Asgardian
to all new lows before ultimately bringing
him some long-awaited emotional resolution.
The developments in Thor's story from Ragnarok
through Endgame didn't seem possible in the
early days of the second phase of the MCU,
and the entire affair stands as a testament
to the inherent potential that the character
possesses.
For all of his heroics and character development
over the years, Thor really is still a gruff
warrior at his core.
That's why he went off in search of a bigger,
badder weapon when Thanos arrived on the scene.
If he could outgun his opponent, he knew he
could win by sheer brute force.
But, while his strong-handed approach to life
has been instrumental on multiple Earth- and
universe-saving occasions, there's one moment
in Endgame that exposes how nasty Thor's belligerent,
competitive attitude can get when he's off
duty.
When Rocket and Hulk arrive at Thor's hut,
the trio of heroes catch up on the past five
years and discuss future plans while Korg
plays Fortnite off to the side.
At one point, Korg informs Thor that "NoobMaster69"
is giving him a hard time again, at which
point the God of Thunder grabs his friend's
headset and delivers a thundering string of
threats, including literally flying to the
person's house and tearing off his arms.
The little spurt of cyberbullying exposes
the fact that, while Thor's brazen approach
to life may work out well in the hero department,
when it comes to the regular, everyday stuff
he sometimes ends up looking like a bully.
Thor is an alien.
He can fly around the universe using the Bifrost.
The guy survived floating through space until
the Guardians of the Galaxy picked him up
in Infinity War.
And yet, over the years he's become one of
the most oddly relatable characters in the
MCU.
In spite of the rather exaggerated nature
of everything he does, the truth is, Thor
has had some very human struggles over the
years, a fact that is on full display during
Endgame.
He'd suffered heartbreak and emotional trauma
more than once leading up to the film, but
it's in Endgame that we come face to face
with a Thor that is truly relatable.
As he grapples with his emotions, struggles
through depression, and faces the consequences
for his actions, it becomes easier than ever
to connect with the god on entirely new levels.
On a more practical note, his hefty appearance
also creates new frontiers.
Thor's bod opens up a whole new world for
cosplayers to connect with their favorite
Avenger without feeling inadequate in the
process.
While the Son of Odin is a heavy hitter whether
he's sporting a beer gut or not, when you
break it down, all the extra weight and years
of inactivity in Endgame do seem to take their
toll on the Asgardian's ability to keep up.
"Thor!"
"Is he asleep?"
Thor is definitely slower this time around.
In fact, Hemsworth filmed scenes with weights
on his hands and ankles to change the appearance
of his walk.
He also doesn't make quite as big of a splash
in the final battle as he did, say, when he
arrived in Wakanda in Infinity War.
In fact, this time around he finds himself
so outmatched by Thanos that he ultimately
needs to be bailed out by the Mjolnir -wielding
Steve Rogers.
"Give me that.
You have the little one."
Of course, it's natural that he'd be a bit
rusty after taking five years off and packing
on so many pounds.
There's no question that the effects of his
new lifestyle ultimately ended up hampering
his battlefield prowess a bit, which is an
unfortunate turn for fans of Thor's epic approach
to combat.
For all of the ups and downs the "Bro Thor"
character goes through in Endgame, hands down
one of the best things about the entire film
is his final decision to join the Guardians
of the Galaxy.
While his presence will be missed on the Avengers,
the thought of an overweight, self-confident
Thor, unhampered by responsibilities, traipsing
around the cosmos with the Guardians in search
of adventure is the definition of awesome.
The thought that the entire scenario will
be overseen in Guardians 3 by the offbeat
genius of director James Gunn makes it that
much more appealing.
From adding some muscle to the already impressive
team, to his ongoing bickering with Star-Lord
over who's really in charge, the possibilities
are tantalizing.
We'll have to wait and see if the "Asgardians
of the Galaxy" really will be a full-length
feature affair or if it'll just be a passing
nod as Thor heads into the unknown for a fourth
solo film.
Then again, maybe we'll get both.
Here's hoping.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.